Community Pride on 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Finley Automotive Group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
you know Findlay automotive group the
sponsors of this next segment they're
all about cars and Community this time
they're partnering with the Leukemia and
Lymphoma Society so let's welcome Tyler
Corder and LLS 2022 honored hero Dylan
Castle Tyler how you doing I'm doing
wonderful how are you Rocky I'm good how
are you doing I'm doing awesome how are
you welcome to the show I'm doing well
okay I'm excited to tell everybody about
this partnership you know how long have
you guys been involved and what's been
your involvement with the society sure
so we've uh this is a charity we've been
involved with for a really long time I
actually used to be on their board and
was their board president for a while I
was the chair of their life
I was the chair of their life the night
walk in 2017 and we've had Finley
employees be a man woman of the year
three times we've won that uh
fundraising competition so really
involved but it's a great cause we love
it because it's out to cure blood cancer
and there's been tremendous progress
made so I like where the dollars go they
go to help people like Dylan Dylan uh
want to bring him on today he's a cancer
your patient cancer survivor is beaten
his uh he's winning his fight with
leukemia so really excited to have him
involved with the light the night walk
this year let him tell a little bit
about what they got going on Dylan
please tell us more
Dory and how the society has helped you
and of course yes so the Leukemia
Lymphoma Society has really brought
together a sense of community for me
when I went through my treatment I was
diagnosed in June of 2020. so kova 19
had just hit we were under a lockdown so
having that sense of community and that
backbone behind me along with my
family's support really helped me get
through that Journey with my I was
diagnosed with acute lymphoblastic
leukemias where I came from wow we're so
happy that you're here to be able to
tell your story and and tell everybody
how they can help this cause with you
both um so let's talk about the the
night walk so the light the night walk
is a signature fundraiser for the
Leukemia Lymphoma Society every year
it's a wonderful walk and uh it's in the
evening and people carry different color
lanterns based on whether they're a
Survivor or there's just supporting
someone or if they're honoring someone
that lost their fight so it's a great
event and uh Dillon's the honored hero
this year that's a big part of the event
and uh it's going to be out at where
it's out at West Charleston okay okay
we're seeing photos of it right now
um now I want to know Dylan you know
what what gives you that title how do
you earn that honored hero title so it
gives a great question so being able to
be honored hero you do have to go
through the treatment yourself um so I'm
actually still in active treatment it's
a about a four year course for me I have
achieved remission but like I said you
know the maintenance treatments so you
either have to be a Survivor or going
through the active treatment which I'm
kind of qualified for both okay um so I
was able to do that for them this year
if there's somebody watching that that
you can encourage right now what would
you tell them I would tell them to keep
keep on fighting it's not easy by any
means I truly understand that some of
those lowest points of my life was going
through that that treatment but knowing
that you know the leukemia Society is
behind standing behind them you know and
we're coming out here we're raising
these funds and to come if you can't
make the event please do join virtually
there's many ways to help sponsor there
you go thank you so much Bill
thing you're doing it's great being here
thanks Rocky of course Finley Automotive
Group thank you for sponsoring this
segment the Leukemia and Lymphoma
Society bring you light the night walk
to learn more all you got to do is call
702-436-4220